i want you just to go back and visualize
your first
sexual experience your first sexual
memory could you go tell your parents
about it and they said
that's great that's a milestone in
development let's go get pizza
or was it secretive was it guilt-ridden
100 of us is the second what happens
then
is that sex is cross-wired with things
like shame
guilt secrecy what made you want to
write a book called no more mr nice guy
i was one of the people that needed the
book i grew up really hiding
everything about myself and that's
pretty typical of nice guys what causes
us to be the way we are to be nice men
nice guys
is it more mom-driven is it more
dad-driven you know a lot of therapy
kind of begins with mom and dad but
that's not the whole story there's a
multitude of things that can
cause a guy to internalize this life
paradigm that have got to be good
my fault to get liked and loved how much
does your first sexual experience have
to do with
how you look at sexual relationships
later on in life everything it has
everything to do with it so we're all
screwed up
we're all screwed up let's dive into
this
find ways to teach that sex is a healthy
gift and hot what are the parameters in
which we can use it in the most healthy
way
how does a grown man who dealt with some
of these scars as a boy
deal with it now as an adult i think
that's what adulthood is is learning to
differentiate to say
who am i what do i want what's important
to me and then live
that
so a couple weeks ago on the podcast i
was talking about a book no more mr nice
guy and i said listen
this book i've recommended to thousands
of men i think every man needs to read
it
after i recommend it i got a lot of
letters tweet people said
i can't believe you recommended this
book i disagree
i agree i love it it's awesome this
entire time while i was talking about
how amazing of a book this is that
everybody needs to read
my booker reached out to the author
and dr robert glover was nice enough of
a guy to say
yes don't say that yes
how you doing i'm well this morning good
to see you
yes i i know you're in puerto vallarta i
see the traffic behind you the weather
looks pretty good it doesn't look like
what's going on in the northeast right
now
it it is not there's a reason i live in
puerto vallarta
and and right now just read the news and
it's it's not hard to understand why
no you're you were telling me earlier 75
degrees beats uh 37 in dallas so you
know you're
double the fun that we're having here in
dallas but uh look let's get let's get
right into it i mean this book you know
i remember the first time i read it
and um i left after i read the book
to dinner with two my friends and and
they're gonna watch us and they're gonna
know exactly who they are when they
watch this
and we went to dinner and one of my
friends you know he was talking about
his wife and you don't know what i'm
going through and this this and his that
and
i said you know what i said you got one
challenge he says what i said you're a
nice guy
and he says what are you talking about i
said there's a book you got to read
so i give him the book i say you got to
read this book
this has got to be six seven years ago
and
they leave well a month later i get a
call from the other friend who's not
necessarily a nice guy
he doesn't need to read the book he
definitely doesn't need to read the book
the other one did he calls me says man
you don't even know what's been
happening with him you know ever since
he read the book he's changed his
lifestyle
his wife is upset they're fighting
they're this i don't know if you did the
writing recommend him the book you know
i just don't know if it was a safe thing
i said they're gonna be okay so anyways
i've recommended your book to so many
people and it's life-changing but i
guess the opening question just to get
some guys
who maybe don't know the story behind
your book is what made you want to write
a book called no more mr nice guy
all right i that's because i was a nice
guy i
i was one of the people that needed the
book you know like your friend
and uh you know i thought that was a
great thing i thought i'm a nice guy i'd
tell people that 30 years ago i would
i would have brag i'm a nice guy i i i'm
different than other men
i'm not a jerk i treat women well
i'm generous i'm kind i avoid conflict
and i thought that was all really good
stuff until my second wife
told me one day i i can't take you
anymore you've got to go get help
and i go what do you mean you know
you're the one that's angry all the time
and moody and upset i'm i'm
i do everything to try to make
everything right she's like i can't take
your passive aggressiveness
anymore i already had a phd in marriage
and family therapy
and i didn't even know what that meant
right let me get this
so you have a phd marriage in therapy
marriage and family therapy correct
and she's telling you i can't stand your
passive aggressiveness
and i didn't know what she meant and and
she said everybody thinks you're such a
nice guy
but you're not so nice to me you hurt me
you do hurtful things you
embarrass me in public you you bring up
things you
you think you're teasing but it hurts
and said you need to go get help
and said i'm going to leave you if you
don't so i mean that was like a big
stick upside the head so
i went i went to go get help to find out
why my
why me being a nice guy didn't make her
treat me better and didn't make her
appreciate me and want to have sex more
luckily i landed in some good spots i
landed in a 12-step
group and then with a therapist and then
i joined a men's group and realized
that me being quote a nice guy
was um it was a put on i i i was trying
to win
people's love and approval and trying to
avoid
any kind of disapproval so i was really
uh
uh on on it uh on authentic
and uh wasn't particularly very honest
and and was
a difficult person to be around now how
tough is it for you
to have a phd in you know marriage and
you know for you to go to therapy to say
listen i need help on my marriage how
how embarra how tough was that for you
to do at that time well
it was challenging because um yeah
i grew up in a real fundamental
christian church my father was critical
i kind of grew up during the feminism
that all men are bad and all this so
i i grew up really hiding everything
about myself and that's pretty typical
of nice guys we keep a lot of things in
we hide a lot of things
we only show people enough of what we
think will make them approve of us or
not disapprove
so it was challenging but i tell you
what it i i loved it actually
that group i mentioned i went to was a
12-step group for sex addicts
because my wife kept saying you're a sex
addict so i went to a 12-step group for
sex addicts and and quickly found out i
was not a sex addict i wasn't having
enough sex to be a sex addict
but these guys that were there man their
lives were really
messed up and and i i just went as this
this group met like at 6 00 a.m every
once a week i got excited about going to
this group at 6 00 a.m
because for the first time in my life i
got to just open up
i got to just talk about me and reveal
me and let
and let out what i've come to to know is
toxic shame
this belief that i'm not good enough i'm
i'm not lovable
and that was so just liberating to go
and just say hey i thought about this or
i have this dark
you know part of me or i did this thing
in the past or i want to go do this
thing
and the guys just go thanks for sharing
robert and i'm going wow that wasn't bad
at all
and and i got in with a good therapist
um and i got later got into a good men's
group
and i mean it takes work if you're used
to hiding
parts of yourself it is a challenge but
that's one thing i say
i i repeat to every everybody you know
they're in the book
go find safe people to do this work with
go find somebody you can start
revealing yourself to talking to getting
more accurate feedback
of who you are and who you're not robert
let me ask you when your wife said you
need to go see somebody because i think
you're sex addict was she saying that
and was she saying that because you
constantly
wanted to have sex with her was she
saying that because you were promiscuous
there was two pieces one is yes i wanted
to have sex with her and
and she we had a highly sexual
relationship before we got married and
on our honeymoon she said aren't you
glad that now that we're married we
don't have to pretend to like sex
anymore
i thought wait a minute i wasn't
pretending you know
you're hot you're sexy you're amazing i
mean and so
so she just like shut down sexually so
yeah i did
keep pursuing her for sex and then i did
act out
i had an inappropriate relationship with
a woman that she found out about
and um and she said you got to go get
help and and
i said that was the big stick upside my
head because if it wasn't for that
i'd still probably be doing that same
kind of stuff i was doing back then
now now what what events uh what events
causes
men to become nice guys like you know
for me
obviously in the book you you i mean
i've read your book multiple times but
to the audience that hasn't uh
read the book what causes us to be the
way we are to be nice men nice guys
is it more mom-driven is it more
dad-driven or it could be both in a
different way
you know that's a good question and and
you know when i saw the previous
uh session when you talked about my book
you talked about mama's voice
and we can come back to the mama's voice
because that that can be a part of it
when i started
and here's here's how i actually started
kind of really diving into the nice guy
thing as
as a therapist i had clients coming to
me guys with their wives or girlfriends
and they were saying the same things i
was
i'm a nice guy i'm one of the nicest
guys you'll ever meet i treat her better
than her ex i'm raising her kids i do
everything to make her happy
it's never enough she's never happy she
never wants to have sex anymore
blah blah blah blah blah so i i started
a no more mr nice guy men's group that
was about 25 years ago and just started
writing chapters to give these guys and
that's what later turned into the book
but when i first started working with
other men i first realized hey i'm not
the only guy
out there thinking if i'm just a nice
guy everybody will love me and like me
and i'll get my needs met
i thought maybe we were all the same
that we all had the same kind of
programming to
turn us into the nice guys but the more
i worked with men the more i realized
there's there's a multitude of things
that that can cause a guy to internalize
this life paradigm this world paradigm
that i've got to be good
my faults to to get liked and loved um
i think a lot of nice guys are just
naturally easy going
guys i mean probably as little boys we
were just probably
a lot of us were easy going my my mother
tells every woman i've ever been
involved with at some point says
bobby never did like conflict which i'm
thinking
who does of course i didn't like
conflict
but that's just me that's my temperament
some people love to fight
um my my present wife loves to fight you
know
she'll pick a fight just for fun and um
so i tend to attract those people
so what i found was is it a lot of guys
a lot of the men i work
with tended to have a combination of
either
they were over-involved with their
mothers as little boys and their fathers
were absent
or unavailable or or bad in some way
alcoholic flandering treated their moms
bad
now that's not always the case a lot of
guys i work with nowadays grew up with
with
nice guy fathers and maybe angry or
controlling or dominant
mothers that their fathers would just
say don't don't upset your mother
because that was dad's
you know strategy for dealing with his
wife just don't upset her don't rock the
boat
so i think a lot of things can
contribute to it and and nowadays
you see most young men growing up a lot
grow up in single-parent families so
dads aren't around
almost all boys worldwide grow up in
school systems educational systems that
are dominated by women
and the educational system nowadays is
geared towards educating girls
it really does not suit young people
tell me what you mean by that can you
unpack that
um yeah um i i've got a 35 year old son
and stepson and and now in my third
marriage i've got a 15 year old son
down here in mexico stepson and um the
educational system that expects
boys to sit in a chair that that doesn't
fit them
my son and stepson from my second
marriage my first son
for my first marriage were both like six
foot tall at 12 years old
you know so here they're going to these
you know these little chairs with desks
built into the front of them
they couldn't even get their bodies into
them we'd go to the school and complain
you got to give them bigger deaths
they can't oh we just they aren't
available
and expect adolescent boys especially to
just sit still listen to a teacher
lecture
memorize that [ __ ] regurgitate it on a
test
and and then that's how you get through
school and and even even younger
i often say that you know for a third
grade boy
graduating from third to fourth grade
not only involves learning your reading
writing and arithmetic but how to please
a woman but probably because you had a
female teacher
so the educational system is pretty much
geared to how
how girls tend to learn not how boys to
to really educate boys we probably need
to take them out in the forest
somewhere out in a jungle somewhere and
teach them life skills
and while we're doing it teach them
mathematics and chemistry
you know hands-on learning that's how
boys tend to learn better
so you know so a lot of boys get into
that educational system
um and i did i didn't start studying
until my senior year in high school i
mean
i just didn't care i just i didn't have
to study very hard to just
get by and so but what happens for a lot
of boys they get disenfranchised
and you know the the dropout rate for
adolescent males out of school is just
it's unacceptable because we and then
because what's happening is these guys
not only are not doing well in math and
spelling
they internalize that belief system
there's something wrong with me i'm
stupid i'm not smart enough i'm not good
and all of that stuff is part of that
toxic shame i mentioned
a little bit earlier that we now try to
hide from the world and overcompensate
for
and um so that can turn a boy into a
nice guy it might turn him into an
[ __ ] i mean
it can go different directions but a lot
of it has to do with our basic
temperament
and then these experiences that we have
in in childhood
adolescent that we in i say we
inaccurately internalize
these beliefs about ourself in the world
and that becomes our emotional operating
system
that that now is running the bus as
adults
so so a couple questions for your
observation based on the book and what
you just said right now so one
a boy is raised by a woman who the
father is not in a picture
and the mother is going to be affirming
certain things to him right it's
almost like an affirmation to him as a
person you
raised in a christian family you know
affirmation so hey
when you grow up you're not going to be
like your dad you're going to be a nice
guy you're going to do this you're going
to take care of woman you're never going
to do this you're never going to do it
yes mom yes mom yes mom and you say that
a million times the boy's going to want
to be what mommy wants them to be right
sure
sure and then on the other situation
what you're saying is if i'm off here
you're raised in an environment where
the data is extremely aggressive
extremely hard at core mill you know too
much like way way too much without you
know
being a little bit uh sitting down
values principles
and then later on this boy says i never
want to be like my dad i don't
ever want to be like my dad i'm going to
be a nice guy i'm going to be this i'm
going to be that
and then what they end up realizing in
their 40s is or 30s is the fact that
neither works you know solution is
typically in the middle
is that kind of what you're saying here
well you've described just
one possible scenario of what a child
might grow up with and
yeah my mother told me as a child she
was raising me and my brother
to be different from my father and she
later apologized
for that bless her heart she said that
was not a healthy thing to do
to you as a boy and to alienate you from
your father
so i i you know i i i'll give problems
to her kudos yeah exactly for that
and um and i did have a good
relationship with my father
but he he was moody and critical so
really unpredictable but
he he came to every ball practice i had
took me to the ball
you know took me to the school and went
pitch to me hit flies
you know uh took us camping fishing so
there were good qualities there as well
but yes
i like a lot of nice guys did make the
decision
i want to be different from dad um and
and a lot of
men i work with have made that decision
to be different not only from their
fathers
but all those bad men that they've heard
mothers
girls in junior high complain about oh
those jerks that only want sex blah blah
blah blah blah
or you know if a guy spends any amount
of time
hanging out with women he's going to
hear them complain about men
and then those guys say i don't want to
be that guy if i'm not that guy
then the women will like me and want to
be with me which
that's a whole other story because that
doesn't work at all either that's
another one we can dive into
so there's any number of things that can
contribute to that dynamic of the
of a guy of a young man a boy deciding
it's not okay to just be me
it's not okay to just be who if i'm if
i'm a little bit like dad i don't know
that's a bad thing
and and what what a lot of guys tell me
a lot of nice guys that i work with
once they kind of hit that age whether
it's in their 20s or 30s or 40s when
they start asking
well who am i really all they realize
is all they've ever heard growing up is
don't be this don't be this don't be
this don't be that
no real supportive be yourself you know
pursue your passions
do what you love be true be honest be
authentic
and so all we've heard is don't be and
we don't we have no clue what to be
because of that that's interesting when
you're saying that so so so on this
topic with fathers and mothers that
we're talking about
uh uh affirming imagine i'm watching
this right now
and i am a 45 year old parent and i'm
sitting here saying
shoot man i've been making all these
mistakes you know i'm a mother or i'm a
father i'm like
i tell my son this and i tell my son
that and i'm
you know too much of this what is the
right approach
with raising in this specific topic men
what is the right approach to raising
boys into mental
they themselves are one they're going to
be confident grown adults that are going
to go out there and
pursue their passion and make an impact
and at the same time
not feel like they have to conform to
every situation that's a good question
and as i said my you know my background
is a marriage and family therapy so
about 25 years out of practice working
with couples and with families
and um you know there's no one right
here's how you raise kids i mean
yeah good luck um raising kids a lot of
it is just you know just get through it
and and don't do too much damage but one
thing i told
every family that came in i told every
parents
you're gonna mess your kids up every
parent does we're imperfect we're flawed
you know we don't inherently know how to
parent and and we're gonna mess our kids
up
and what i tell parents the real the
real issue is not
how you mess them up but how you recover
from it so like for example my mother
coming to me when i'm an adult saying
hey i made a mistake you know that that
wasn't a good thing to say
i'm going to raise you to be different
from your father that was recovery
from the mistake so in terms of dads and
our kids right dad's dads and our sons
um one of the things i the term i use
with dads is
learn to speak your child's language you
know a lot of times we dads you know if
our kid likes the things we like
you know if we're into sports or if
we're into cars or
and you know if our kid likes it we can
bond with them yeah but oftentimes our
kids are into stuff that we're not into
you know my kids grew up playing video
games i you know they didn't exist when
i was young so
i wasn't into video games but i still
tried to learn
what they liked about them and what was
important to them about them and
and and i would encourage them to do it
but then also set some limits around it
because they didn't need to play video
games
24 7. so the word that
is used in the technical word for for
teaching children to be themselves is
called
differentiation where you actually teach
a child
to value who they are so if they're if
they're attracted to music
you encourage them to to to get into
music if they're attracted to sports
you you encourage that if they're
they're drawn to to mathematics you
encourage
them to be themselves and and that's
that's really hard for most parents and
that's really difficult in most cultures
most cultures are built around something
called fusion
and you know the culture you come from
is a highly fused culture
you've got to do what everybody you know
what family says to do don't embarrass
the family
you know uh in other asian cultures you
got to be a doctor you got to be an
engineer you got to
go to mit you got to go to stanford
that's fusion where we tell our kids
you've got to be this you've got to grow
up with this religion
you've got to believe in god the way we
believe in god
differentiation is a person's ability to
ask themselves
what do i want what feels right to me
what's most important to me
and then follow through on that even if
there's pressure from outside to conform
and let go of that or the anxiety and
neurotic guilt between your own ears it
says oh no
i'm going to get in trouble oh no this
won't work out so differentiation
i i think that's what adulthood is is
learning to differentiate to say
who am i what do i want what's important
to me and then live
that but again culture does not really
encourage
differentiation it encourages sameness
and fusion
so so that was a very uh
well eloquently explained and described
i appreciate you for that
uh when it comes down to us growing up
okay men specific
today is specific to men right when it
comes to us growing up
men have a lot of different events that
can happen to them that could
dictate their character or the way they
respond to things right for example
we just talked about the influence of
parents right mom dad single mother
married they're together dad's
aggressive you know passive mon passive
that passive-aggressive dad
nice guy dad passes down that to the sun
you know aggressive that pat you know
sometimes i don't want to be like my dad
when i grow up i want to be like my dad
when i grow up
but but also outside of that let's put
the parents aside you know most of the
time you don't spend time around your
parents you know you're away you're at
school you know
eight ten hours a day you're really
around your dad maybe a couple hours a
day when he comes home as a kid
yeah and you're seeing them on the
weekends and then you're seeing mom
uh arana you're around your sibling so
you're probably the most around your
classmates teach your school
eight to ten hours a day then maybe
siblings more
if you have one then maybe friends and
then you got parents right
parents are actually not at the top we
spend most time with
so events that happen in life and
sometimes you know
men you don't know how to process this
with anybody what could it be a
humiliating loss
a bad breakup a a friend backstab in you
a fight in school where a guy punches
you in the face and everybody says oh my
gosh
johnny got knocked out you know uh
a a thing that you had that people make
fun of you're short you're tall you're
fat you're skinny you're
your hand looks funny your feet look
funny you know your
body is awkward you walk awkward why are
you so slow why are you so
ugly so these things stay right and yeah
i like a
13 year old boy is gonna go talk to
somebody about it you know typically
you know you internalize it because
we're so embarrassed to talk about this
right
how does how does a grown man who dealt
with some of these scars as a boy
deal with it now as an adult and from
your experience of 25 years
what have you noticed that affected a
man
the most with events that took place
when they were boys
not from parents outside of parents
that's a good question those are all
good examples because
yeah we're not who we are just because
of what mom and dad did you know a lot
of therapy kind of begins with mom and
dad but that's not the whole story
and that period of a you're talking
about typically between about 15 and 21
is a developmental stage in the human
personality
where we go we're not so dependent
anymore on mom and dad say around 14
15 years old we start wanting to connect
more
with peers and have approval of our
peers uh
we start noticing the opposite sex and
they start looking interesting to us and
we want that
in our life as well so in that period
from about 15 to about 21
it is one of those really powerful
developmental periods it's when we try
on
a lot of things who am i really you know
am i really somebody that has purple
hair or a lot of piercings or tattoos or
smokes
or you know is the jock or you know is
really smart or
we try that stuff on and around the end
of that developmental period
it gets solidified into our adult
personality so that's
pretty much you've got that the early
childhood influences that are mom
dad siblings and then that adolescents
that that combine and get solidified
in early adulthood and then we just kind
of go into adulthood
being that person without without really
even evaluating does that serve me very
well
so you're right all those kinds of
things
pile up and that's one reason i i tell
guys yeah i would tell anybody but since
i mainly work with men now
i tell me find safe people especially a
group i love
men's groups i've i'm i'm in a men's
group to
at this day um where where i've been in
this program
for three years because i still need
that support
and i still need the connection i need
the tribe i need the connection with men
and i need a safe place to be me and and
in that program we do a lot of revealing
of self which i've been doing for years
anyway
was started in that first 12-step group
but to answer your question
when a guy can get into a safe
environment typically with a group of
other men
that where it's safe to be open where
it's safe to reveal themselves
and you start hearing other people
struggling with the same adult issues
you struggle with
having the same wounds and pains from
childhood that you've had or similar
anyway
that there's a release in that there's a
catharsis in that that go oh
maybe i'm not messed up maybe i'm not
unique maybe i'm not the only one like
this
and that is so liberating to start
realizing
you know all this stuff i internalized
inaccurately about me
was just the stuff that happens in life
everybody goes through these kinds of
pains i remember one guy telling me
um adult black male
um you know big guy so here you got a
big black guy that people tend to you
know react to in a certain stereotypical
way
but just true blue nice guy just wanted
to please everybody
and a core piece of his wounding i
remember he shared in a workshop
that um i said what what's your deepest
shame what was your deepest
piece about you that you were afraid
people knew they'd reject you
he stole a car stereo out of a car when
he was like 15.
you know one of those stupid adolescent
male things that every
every stupid adolescent male does
something like that
and he had packed that around his entire
life
as proof that he was this terrible human
being and if anybody found out
and he shared that in this group of guys
and guys are looking at him going
man we all did stupid stuff and then
everybody started sharing their stupid
stuff they did it
and like that liberated him in just that
moment to go you mean i'm not this
terrible human being everybody goes no
you're actually really normal you know
that was a normal thing to do at 15
years old
so having that safe place to just reveal
and hear
other men reveal their stories it gives
us oh okay we've all been through the
same battle we've all been the same war
we're comrades we're brothers in arms
we're not wounded we may be scarred but
we're not messed up
yeah i remember a friend of mine so it's
so interesting you're saying that story
about you know sometimes you sit there
you're trying to help somebody recreate
their identity and they have a
disconnect with they don't believe
they're capable of doing something
special with their lives because they
said
you don't know who i am you don't know
what i've done in my if you knew when i
was 15 years old what i would you would
know why i can't ever succeed in life
and they're clinging they're hanging on
to that one and they're not letting go
for them to be able to pursue their
their dreams but you know i had a friend
of mine
uh who uh i loved i mean this kid i
loved this kid he was funny
he was a leader he was strong he was uh
cool to be around cocky you know
good with the girls he was he was a good
guy right he was a
he was not a nice guy but he was a good
guy but there's a challenge he faced
every time i was around his dad his dad
would slap him upside the head
he would he would hit him he would
embarrass him in front of us and i've
seen him
i've seen his dad hit him hardcore many
many times
and uh uh he was so afraid and wanted to
please his dad so much that later on he
ended up you know i don't know if this
was the reason
but i took him he was he got addicted to
a pot and coke then
uh ecstasy then it led to xanax and it
led to
you know uh vicodin and he ended up
killing himself with vicodin he took 50
vacants in one day
reading the bible he they found him
uh sleeping on top of the bible dead and
i'm sitting there you know as a friend
you sit there try to process what led to
this situation you know what led to
somebody willing to take how much pain
does one have to go through
to be willing to take the beautiful
thing that we have which is life to
experience
all these different crazy things
together but there's so many things that
happen
in a childhood or as a young adult where
you don't talk to somebody about it and
if you do it's almost like a release
yeah hey man i'm going through problems
dude i am as well it's cool you know we
all got some screwed up lives
like you said it's sometimes half the
challenges trying to recover from the
mistake you made as a parent
to come down and talk to your kids but
now that we talked about that let's go a
different direction the direction i want
to go with right now
is the effects of our first sexual
partner has
in how we are as men later on and how we
first start experiencing sex so
if you talk to 50 different guys you're
going to hear
50 different stories of their first
sexual experience but
some of them will be the same so what is
it one is you're working at a place you
have a co-worker
and you know you know you have a
part-time job you get off at 10 o'clock
at jack in a box and you go in the car
you experience and next thing you know
boom you're having sex oh
you had sex then it's another girlfriend
you had steady girlfriend
you're with her six 12 months and you
both agree that why don't we try having
sex because you've already tried
everything else
then you try sex you're like okay it was
cool but it wasn't you know as crazy as
i thought it was going to be
and then or you first learn how to
masturbate and you
realize my gosh this is the greatest
invention ever why was god so nice
and you you're like this is phenomenal
you know what this feels like and you
know the first time around no one knows
how to do you right maybe as good as you
know how to do yourself right
you know or you just go with somebody
and you're maybe our bigger guy and so
older woman kind of sees an older guy
you find an experienced
woman who's a little bit more nurturing
teaching
she teaches you and you know hey here's
how you do this is this your first time
she kind of knows how to nurture you how
much does your first sexual experience
have to do with
how you look at sexual relationships
later on in life
everything it has everything to do with
it so we're all screwed up
we're all screwed up let's dive into
this because here's a question i asked
i didn't give you the other 46 ways
people have sex the first time and i
don't want to get into it i'm just
giving you four of them exactly so
uh a thing i often do in my workshops
with men
is that i will ask them the question
really that you've brought up
i'll say i want you just to go back and
visualize
your first sexual experience your first
sexual memory
and for most of us is it's earlier than
adolescence it's you know
the first time you realize it it does
feel good to touch your penis uh
the the first time you see a woman naked
maybe when you you're you're
seven and you're with the neighbor girl
and she shows you hers and you show her
yours
maybe it's your first kiss maybe it's
your first wet treat maybe it's your
first
you know masturbation or maybe for sex
doesn't matter i said whatever it is
whatever comes to mind i want you to
picture it for a minute
and i'll say now let me ask you did this
situation
occur in the open where
it could be seen and known and
celebrated did you could you go tell
your parents about it and they said
that's great that's a milestone in
development let's go get pizza
or was it hidden was it secretive
was it guilt-ridden was it you know
shrouded in secrecy and and you know 100
of us is the second it was hidden clumsy
guilt-ridden sin filled kind of kind of
like
i grew up in that church that said you
know sin is sinful dirty and evil so
save it for the one you love
you know is it with our first sexual
experiences
were like that which it is probably for
99.9
of the people on the planet this hidden
secretive guilt-ridden toxic
shame-filled what happens then is that
sex
which is the most amazing gift to you
know the
human race sex gets cross-wired
with things like shame guilt hidden
secrecy clumsiness stress anxiety
fear right those get cross-wired
together and those other things i just
mentioned
aren't as powerful as sex but they're
all equally powerful stuff
guilt shame fearings are equally
powerful now we combine them with sex
and they get cross-wired and basically
sex then gets on steroids but gets
cross-wired
to those things to where sex only feels
normal
if it's hidden if it's secretive if it's
guilt-ridden if it's shame-filled
and that's how most of us grow into
adulthood and then think we're going to
have
normal satisfying you know
you know sex with another human being
that always works out well
and and that the kids can know that
we're upstairs doing it because there's
no shame
not none of that happens so that is why
for example
you know i i i i think probably 80
of men have issues with porn you know
either looking at it occasionally but
feeling guilty about it or compulsively
can't stop looking at it
and a lot of married men it's easier to
go jack off to porn than try to make
your wife happy
so let's just go get that done so what
happens that that feels normal to us
and that's another piece that i found if
you get men into a group and start
talking about these issues
we can start uncoupling sex
from this the shame the darkness the
hidden the secrecy the guilt
and we start uncoupling them and then
sex can really become this really
interesting adult uh authentic
honest transparent adventure that we can
share
with ourselves and and with another
person but that does take some work
because most of us grow up in that kind
of
that dark shame shame container around
sex
so here's what i took away from what you
just said so i think what you're saying
is the next time
your son comes up to you and he tells
you you had sex for the first time
high five the kids say i'm so proud of
you buddy great job
go get them do it again is that what
you're saying let me put it in context
cause like i said i've got uh i
my my son and my stepson for my second
marriage are both in their mid-30s now
so they're adult males
um both fathers and when they
before they hit adolescence you know
that i mean this is this is the juggling
act of being a parent
we wanted them to feel comfortable with
their sexuality but also
wanted to have enough boundaries and
parameters that you know we didn't give
them enough rope to hang themselves
right so that's the challenge of being
yeah so we tried to you know we let them
see
us be affectionate and loving well we
didn't have sex in front of the kids but
you know we didn't hide the fact that we
did they knew you said you you do have
sex in front of us no no no no we did
not but
don't recommend that no no no we did not
but we didn't hide the fact that we did
have sex right
the kids could know that you know mom
they knew that mom and dad were upstairs
humping as they would put it
so but we were trying to have parameters
like for example when when you know when
my boys were like 15
that's when like broadband internet you
know really came around
we couldn't wait to get broadband
internet when we did
the kids were online all the time
stealing music on nabster and looking at
porn
so we we tried everything because that
we didn't think that was healthy
right we wanted them to have healthy
sexuality for example we'd go to costco
and buy
condoms by the gross and put them in a
big bowl
in the living room and told the kids
pass these out to your friends
we told the kids when you were at the
point where you are ready to have sex
come home have it in your own bedroom
don't go do it in a car somewhere don't
go
sneak around doing it do it in your own
bedroom now that actually let us
be more informed with what's going on in
their life than if they're sneaking
around doing it
and and and because we did not push it
into those dark places now we did still
try to keep boundaries on it like i
remember telling my stepson
you know when he when he discovered porn
and you know his mom would find videos
and stuff in his drawer
and then she'd freak out about it and
and i said all right let me handle it
and i'd tell him listen keep all your
porn in the drawer i'm not gonna let
your mom go through it
i've already told her off limits your
room is off limits i said but
i will occasionally look and see and if
there's stuff in there that i think you
don't need
you're his way i said i i will take it
out
i'll tell you i've taken it i'll tell
you why meaning you're going to borrow
it from them for you to watch it or
you know that's a good excuse right now
i had for your own good i had to take
this out of your drawer
so some this is a little too good for
you
where did you find this this is amazing
so we would try to have boundaries right
but but also let them have the freedom
to develop a sexuality that that was not
repressed because if you think about it
our ancestors you go back a couple
hundred thousand years
our ancestors started having sex at
pulber puberty
that i mean that was just what's wired
into us now we tell kids yeah
you know you're hot wired to have sex at
14 but we're going to make you wait till
18 or 21
and it's a sin if you do it before then
or you know that
that just that just messes them up now
i'm not saying don't encourage your kids
to have sex
but find ways again this is the
balancing act of parents
find ways to to teach that sex
is a healthy gift and
hot what are the parameters in which we
can use it
in the most healthy way when you said
you had guidelines for your boys what
were the guidelines is it kind of like
look no more than one girl in a bed you
know never
get together with your girlfriend's
friend you know what were the guidelines
well
the guidelines were number one around
sex wait as long as possible
wait as long as possible to put your
penis in a vagina
why is that why why why is that a good
thing i mean i'm with you unless i have
three kids and they're one they're going
to watch this and they're going to hold
me accountable to this but i'm
i'm saying why why wait what is the
benefit of waiting
research has just shown from an
emotional point of view the longer you
wait
to to to have your first what what most
people call sex penis and a vagina
the longer you wait the the more mature
you seem to be and
the better experience tends to be with
it and how you adapt to it
another reason one thing i told my boys
is i'm going to throw out one rule of
thumb is maybe you don't put your penis
in a vagina until you're 100 ready to be
a dad
because you know that does happen and
and so
i that was one guideline you know you
could scare the hell out of a boy
well that's maybe you may wait till 40
and be like the 40 year old virgin type
of scenario that's okay
you know you can do a lot of other
things that don't turn you into a dad
that are still fun
you know and that's the thing we say to
have fun
but but have respect for the person
you're with well
the kids had it drummed into them like
say with the bowl of condoms
always wear a condom always um
and so that was one of the guidelines a
little bit other guideline
for adolescent males is we told them you
never get in a car in which
anyone's been drinking you anybody else
the driver
we always said if any if you need to get
home and anybody's been drinking
you call us we will not quiz you we will
not ground you we will
you we will get you home safely so there
were you know various
just those guidelines that made that we
were just trying to get our kids through
adolescence without
uh with this as little damage as we
could as we at least could try to
improve now robert do you have a
daughter or was it just
boys i had a stepdaughter who's in her
late 30s as well
and i now have a 14 or 13 year old
stepdaughter and 14 year old
granddaughter
so i i still have girls around in my
life
do you put the best basket of condoms
around your granddaughters
oh when my kids here we haven't done
that yet
my kids in when in my second marriage we
did the daughter as well because if
there's anybody that needs a condom
it's it's the girl right and so uh the
girl how did you have the camera how did
you have the conversation about sex with
your daughter versus your son
or is it the same way it was really much
the same way okay wait as long as
possible
have respect for yourself respect for
the other person
come home if you could now my my
step-daughter from my second marriage
actually moved back to her dad's house
when she was in high school
so it wasn't as relevant there um
because because we weren't the ones that
were in charge of that
but she did take the same principles
there
and her father and stepmother were you
know if you all right you're gonna have
a boyfriend
you can bring him home so i you know i
know a lot of parents cringe at that oh
you know they're bringing their
boyfriend and their girlfriend home
but man i i just would prefer they
they'd be safe
in their own home rather than in a car
somewhere or doing something stupid or
rushed or risky and you know again it's
that stuff that we parents
that's not an easy job it's so true you
know i remember i was 13 years old 14
years old and
i come home and my mom's crying i said
mom why are you crying
she was hysterically crying like out of
control crying like she was
i guess the end of the world she says i
found something
i said what would you find mom she says
here come with me huh
come with me let me tell you what i
found oh oh
that's when i was an amateur at hiding
my stash yeah and so the the amateurs
hide their stuff
under the mattress which is it's such a
long but he's never going to look like i
was such an amateur i learned eventually
you gotta you gotta pull the drawer out
and tape it above the drawers like up
here they can't find that or below the
drawer they don't look there
yeah so she found pictures and it was my
favorite pictures from hustler magazine
and penthouse because playboy wasn't as
provocative at that time it was hustler
and penthouse had better quality stuff
and uh she found them and she says
i can't believe you have pictures of
naked women here
how could you i raised you right i said
mom i have a question for you she said
what i said would you rather have me
have pictures of naked women or naked
men
she says no no no naked woman i said
then let me look at my naked woman and
just leave me
yeah you you were a sharp kid by the way
she never
ever condemned me or judged me for it
again she just wanted to make sure if
i'm gonna play my with myself i'm
playing with myself two naked women not
naked
men which could be some feedback to some
others out there but you know
let me let me get back to this let me
get back to this on we're talking about
so
obviously so far we've talked about how
we as parents
raise kids and the effect parents can
have and how our parents
had effects on us and an events on in
our lives that makes us become
embarrassed timid nice guys all this
other stuff
and then the last song we talked about
so far has been sex the influence of
having sex the first time and
what kind of an impact it has etc etc
now let's get to the dating side now
let's get to the dating site so
you know you know you you you've read
the book i think
i heard you somewhere say you read the
uh what was that one book by uh
the the big dating pickup line book the
guy that eventually stayed
away from it the game yeah you know he
doesn't like his book anymore i spoke to
him and he says
i don't like the book i don't like what
i stood for i don't even like the fact
that i wrote that book so
anybody which is him to want to talk to
him
and interview him about his book he
turns down all the interviews he says if
you want to talk to me about
the current version of me i'm interested
but i'm truth yeah the next book was the
truth
exactly he does not want to talk about
you know what it is to be a player
because he's disappointed in
partially with some of the things he
taught so so men then go out there and
you know
you do what you're supposed to do it's
the age to get married why do you need
to get married everyone's getting
married i need to get married so we get
married who do you marry you marry
somebody your family likes somebody you
like and then boom you marry them and
then you pursue that and then
you have kids and you just kind of do
and be the good citizen and then one day
you wake up and you say
man what the hell happened to this
marriage to this relationship you know
what what
why is this thing like a chore a
responsibility like you have to
feel like you have to do backflips to
have sex and you have to do this and
then you realize
maybe you just are not doing it the
right way your approach is not effective
maybe your approach has got to change
how how do you at that point when you're
going through it obviously we talked
about a little bit earlier when you talk
about why i became
mr nice because my wife said you're
passive aggressive you took the uh
the place where you went to but at that
point of the game when a man hits it
where he realizes
maybe this way of being a man is no
longer sexy
seductive attractive to my woman what do
i need to do
to win her over again what do i need to
do to be
and then they hit the wall when when
that happens
what are some things you've seen over
the years that's worked for men to want
to pivot and make adjustments so life
changes a bit with their personal lives
okay so we talk are we talking about
dating or we're talking about
what dating and then we'll go marriage
let's go dating first and we'll go
marriage
okay that's fine because because i i
teach about both
so my background is that i i did not
learn to date until i was in my late 40s
what i did in high school college was
not dating it was i call it nice guy
seduction just you know
hang out with a woman a little while try
to impress her a little bit hide my
sexual agenda from her and then
maybe she'll want to get naked with me
if i hide my sexual agenda you know
try not to be the jerk that i've heard
women complain about
and if i did get a girlfriend i just
hung on to them forever
so i was married to my first two wives
for a total of 25 years
i shouldn't have dated either one of
them probably more than three dates i
mean they're both good people
but they were not good matches for me
now i'm grateful for them both i learned
a lot i grew a lot
and and i wrote a book because of the
second marriage
but i got divorced in my late 40s and i
had no clue how to date now going back
to neil stross
and strauss in the game um that book had
just come out
and and pickup was really on the rise
then
and in that place where else are you
going to go get education about dating
right and so i read the book and you
know learned a lot about it
about about with that and guys gave me
you know podcasts that were starting to
come out and books and videos and david
d'angelo and a lot of people doing the
dating stuff
and i just went out and and just i never
really liked the pickup idea i didn't
like the idea of just approaching a
woman because she was hot and then
hitting on her trying to get her in bed
i never liked that either i understand
where neil is coming from now that he
doesn't like it
but that book actually you know i think
i i like i liked the book i actually
liked it better
than his second book the truth i i was
i'm not a big fan of for
a few reasons you know but that's
another subject but
i don't i'm not a fan of pickup in
general
but it did help me get out of my comfort
zone and get me out talking to people in
general and then
to to women as well and and so i
i learned to to date successfully i
started getting girlfriends
started having sex started having a
relationship and guys started saying
robert what are you doing it's working
teach us and
i never thought i'd be a dating guru and
and but i just started teaching
guys a lot of it just has to do with
being authentic being confident
setting the tone and leading being
comfortable in your own skin
living life on your terms and that's
real attractive
to women in general it's not going to
attract every woman but it's attractive
to
to the feminine now i tell guys if you
if you're walking across a room
just because you like a woman's tits and
you think oh she'd make a good
girlfriend cause i like her tits
that's the stupidest reason to go talk
to a woman i mean you you don't know
i'm surprised you're saying that where
is the wisdom behind that the wisdom is
what happens what do you know about this
person
she may be entitled she may be spoiled
she may be
mercy she may be stupid she may talk too
much she may be a drunk but hey i like
her tits
let's go talk to her and and we men make
some pretty
simple you know relationships that don't
serve us well
so i i i learned to talk to everybody i
just became more of a social animal
and so that's really what i teach men is
is really just how to be more social how
to expand
their social and emotional intelligence
but the thing is the stuff that that i
learned
dating also really does help my
relationship i've been married four
years now to my wife lupita mexican
woman i met her down here
puerto vallarta and um in this in the
skill
sets that made me a competent dater keep
her turned on
to me four years into our marriage right
and and she loves me to death she thinks
i'm amazing she wants
our our our biggest conflict in our
marriage is she wants more sex than i do
so
most guys go hey i want to sign up for
that one
um and she says would you rather have it
be the other way and i said nope
nope this works just fine so going back
to what i was talking about a little bit
earlier of
that differentiated self that means
you're living life on your terms
you're comfortable in your own skin you
like you you like you how you get up and
live your life every day
and my experience when a man is doing
that
living this differentiated living life
on his own terms
living with his purpose and his passion
that makes him amazingly attractive to
the feminine
whether it's the woman he's been married
to for 20 years or just women in the
street
my wife is the typical jealous latina um
and i tell you what she points out
whenever women
are checking me out walking in front of
me too much
jutting a hip out giving me a little
cleavage bend over the waitress
when the waitress is standing a little
too close to me she points all that out
and i just turned 65 a week or so ago
and this still happens
all the time and typically when i'm with
her and typically with much younger
women
and it's not because i'm flirting with
them it's not because
you know i'm so amazingly handsome or or
i'm so amazingly rich
there i i just over time i'm comfortable
in my skin and i live life on my terms
my wife finds that attractive
so do other women and paradoxically the
fact that other women find me attractive
makes my wife jealous but it makes me
more attractive to her as well
she even tells me that she says i get
jealous when i see other women
you know trying to get your attention
she goes but it turns me on
yeah it arouses me so
whether you're a single guy guy in a
relationship there's just there's just
something about living life on your
terms
that just makes and what really makes a
big difference
is you quit really caring so much is
this where a person attracted to me i
don't know it doesn't matter
is is is my woman this way it really
doesn't matter quite as much in fact
one thing i found that has over the four
years married to my wife lupita the
thing that's made the marriage the best
is to be equally okay with whether she's
happy or
unhappy equally okay with whether or not
this marriage makes it or doesn't make
it
then that gets me out of those nice guy
patterns of trying to fix everything
solve everything make her happy
and just be me just keep loving her and
just stay connected to her not trying to
fix
anything and that lets her work through
her own stuff and we get through it
quicker
so again it's that being just being
happy in your own skin and living life
on your terms
i want to read this from your book so
who is a nice guy this is what you say
his relative he is the relative who lets
his wife run the show he is the friend
who will do anything for anybody but
whose own life seems to be in shambles
he is the guy who frustrates his wife
because he's afraid of conflict that
nothing
ever gets resolved he is the boss who
tells one person
what they want to hear then reverses
himself to please someone else he is the
man who lets people walk all over him
because he doesn't want to rock the boat
he is the dependable guy at work who
will never say
no but would never tell anyone if they
were imposing on him and then
characteristics of a nice guy
nice guys seek the approval of others
they try to hide their uh perceived
flaws and mistakes
they put other people's needs and wants
before them they sacrifice their own
personal power and often play the world
victim
they tend to be disconnected from other
men and from their own masculine energy
they co-create relationships that are
less than satisfying
they create situations in which they do
not have very much good
sex and they frequently fail to live up
to their full potential
so now when this nice guy gets married
married what does life look like for a
nice guy like this
i can tell you i've been there yeah
typically he's trying to please his
partner
trying to make her happy trying to avoid
conflict
um a real big manifestation of this is
where he won't bring up
anything that might upset her so he
won't tell her the whole truth about
stuff he'll leave things out
which as you probably know if you if you
want to really upset or trigger a woman
let her find out something that you
hadn't told her about and uh
that that just messes with the trust um
so yeah is that is that avoidance of
conflict the dishonesty they're trying
to please the hiding of things
from her that you don't want her to find
out and and in terms
of sex it's it's usually just a lot of
pleasing and trying to get them into the
mood
it's kind of like well you know sneaking
your sexual agenda up on her or giving
her the back rub
hoping that you know she'll be okay with
that and then sneaking your hand around
to the side of her breast to see if you
know
if she gives a negative reaction or
approval you just offended 95
of men around the world they're going
that's my technique that's my
that's my skill set um and and that
stuff you know the woman knows what
we're doing oh he's giving me the back
rub
because he's open blah blah blah blah
blah and and
that doesn't tend to turn most women on
but we think it we got to sneak our
agenda up
on them and so what happens is
is i find that most women you know most
women you mentioned earlier about when
they respond to my book
the majority of women really like the
book um you know when when it was
published in 2003
barnes and noble the publisher thought
oh this is going to stir up a real
feminist storm it never happened you
know i
maybe have gotten in 19 years six angry
emails from women
almost all of them haven't read the book
but maybe their husband or boyfriend
did and broke up with them and now
they're going ballistic because it's my
book's fault that
and you know i'm thinking when i'm
reading the email going run
guy run i can see why you left this
woman so
i mean women like the idea of a man
being honest
authentic assertive setting the tone and
leading
having a plan showing up with their
sexuality
you know is full force you know right
there and and
most women are going to respond better
to that
than the guy this hidden secretive
pleasing placating avoiding
yeah that's just not a turn-on so so can
we categorize what's good
sex what's bad sex oh that's that's a
good topic to jump into
um i think good sex would probably be
the kind that everybody wants to keep
having again
um that'd be good sex bad sex
in in my experience is anxiety ridden
guilt-ridden shame written um
approval written performance written i
tell men
i hate it when i hear the word sexual
and performance
used in the same sentence sex is not a
performance
sex is showing up and enjoying each
other's bodies
i mean that that's to me is good sex uh
you know i i'm enjoying my partner's
body while she's enjoying my body
it doesn't get any better than that and
if it's uninhibited
wait are you saying like timeline
doesn't matter with performance
you and her both being satisfied you
know you're saying performance is not
tied to good sex so if you do yours
and you're like listen i got mine it was
amazing you light up that little
cigar cigarette and she's sitting there
empty-handed saying dude
what was this all about what you call
that sex
well and here's the thing you know we
can do a deep dive into this
i i think sex and if you know there's
there's a lot of really good
writers out there from dr david snarch
book called passionate marriage he just
passed away a few weeks ago
david data wave superior man osho
uh rajanesh who had you know out in
oregon had that
that clan out there just from some great
great writings about
sex being the most powerful container
for us to do our deepest
work as human beings because sex is at
the core of who we are
you know sex is how we got to be on this
planet uh so it's at the core
of who we are so if we can use sex if a
man and woman man and man woman and
woman doesn't matter how you're paired
up
can can consciously approach sex as as i
call
as a powerful personal growth machine
not just a way to get off not just a way
to get some validation not just a way to
get our partners approval
but as a powerful personal growth
machine everything that shows up in that
container
is is good everything that shows up in
there is opportunity to do
our deepest work we're not going to do
there's nothing else in life that's
going to help us do deeper work
than a conscious sexual container with
another conscious partner
so of course everybody's got to be
enjoying this but i found that when
what happens with a lot of nice guys
especially they they fall into what i
call the white guy shuffle
and and why i call it that is i took
salsa dance lessons for a few years
up in the seattle area and in that in
that particular area
the the term for a guy that just kind of
keeps doing the same move over and over
again
um is called the white guy shuffle i i
it seems appropriate because i
i kind of tended to do that oh i don't
want to risk i don't know that move real
well i'll just keep doing the one i know
and i i had a chinese salsa teacher a
guy named jim chow in seattle so props
to jim chow
mr channel he used to interrupt every
class
and shout at the guys leads be thinking
ahead
what is your next move two or three
moves ahead because if you don't
you're gonna repeat the same old thing
and the woman's gonna get bored and go
find someone else to dance with
and every time he said that i said amen
because that's true about sex so what
happens here's what a lot of nice guys
do
they they do like i said the back rub
the sneak the sex
up on her and and they go okay i want
her to want to have sex with me again
so i'm gonna do what worked last time i
know if i kind of tweaked her nipple
this way last time and then
they kind of went down on her a little
bit and then did that she got off so
i'm gonna do that next time because that
worked the last time
and do you know how quickly that gets
boring to a woman
you know how quickly she's gonna go find
another dance partner
when we show up with the same moves
every time
and so it's that white guy shuffle most
women
long term in relationship a primary
reason a lot of them lose interest in
sex is not because they don't like sex
they just lose interest in the same
damn thing every time i mean i i have no
idea what your wife is like
but you know can she wear the same
outfit to work
in one in a month you know you can
probably wear the same suit
twice a week right she would never do
that
how often does she change her nails do
her hair differently how often does she
want to rearrange the furniture go shoe
shopping
for shoes that she doesn't need but yeah
oh this would be so great with this
outfit
that the feminine needs that variety to
fill it and if we're going to approach
our woman
and bring the same old thing every time
and throw that down and think that's
going to
make her want to come back for more it
doesn't but
here's here's the the paradox the irony
if two people don't have agendas
and are not trying to perform and each
time they get together
it's just an exploration of what feels
good what what's cool about this
person's
body with my body oh that that seems to
be getting us off or
or or you know what what stories can i
tell this person to get them aroused or
what
and and in his play and as we learn to
be in our bodies and pay attention
and move the sexual energy around and
and and play with it with each other
i mean it that's good sex that's fun
very cool so i think everybody probably
ordered those four books you recommended
with the authors of how to get better at
sex as well as yours
people are probably rewinding right now
writing the titles of those books if
anybody's kind of trying to see what
those books are we're going to put the
links
below as well but let me continue here
in a couple other items before we wrap
up
here here's a couple items so women
will say many times they're attracted to
bad boys right
so they're dating a bad boy and it's
like man i freaking love this guy but
you know if i can only get him to only
just want to want to be with me
why does he want to be with half the
girls in the club i'm good enough why
can't you just be with me
and after one guy you know after
one girl she catch a second girl she
catches
text instagram twitch like you know what
i'm
done then they go try to fight a very
strong you know devout christian boy
who's never been with a
you know girl before maybe she he's had
one girlfriend and
i'm going to play it safe and then
they're going to play it safe
and then they're also disappointed
then they go back to the bad boy then
they miss the safe boy
and they're going back and forth so now
on the other side
if you're the bad boy and you've gone
through seven relationships and they've
all said
dude you have problem with relationship
you have problem with commitment and
you're hearing this
you have a commitment issue you have a
commitment issue and so this sea ward
scares the hell out of the bad boy
commitment issue commitment is your
commitment issue
and eventually maybe his testosterone
level goes from 1200
to six hundred to four hundred or maybe
he doesn't need to have seven
girlfriends anymore like he did before
he says you know what i'm cool with just
one right now
and he decides to become the good boy
right
and he also ends up miserably failing
where is the happy medium here
well i'm not a big fan of happy mediums
okay i often say i don't know where the
tipping point is between two toxic
extremes
you know so most of us i don't think the
good life comes from happy mediums
typically
most people that that have a big life
are living at the extreme somewhere um
and and you know you you've been
successful in your life and
and by being success you didn't become
successful by finding happy mediums
in places now we do need to decide
what's not serving us
and and remove that stuff from our life
so the the question you ask is actually
the book i'm writing right now that i've
been working on and hopefully to have
done
uh later next year uh around a topic
that i call positive
emotional tension and the basic premise
and i had this this kind of aha
revelation
uh 15 years ago running on a beach here
in vallarta and i don't know where it
came from
but i finished my run and all of a
sudden this voice in my head said
women have to have emotional tension
and i just kind of pondered that for a
minute that thought and thought and then
it kind of got clearer
that women have to have emotional
attention to tension
yeah oh when tension
women have to have emotional tension to
feel attraction towards a man
and sexual arousal towards a man and
it's like all of a sudden my brain
caught on fire and i ran back to the
hotel i stayed out got a legal pad
wrote about a dozen pages of what that
meant
and it explained everything to me
because i've been a marriage therapist
um i've been married that time married
twice i was single at that time
and and i thought this explains
everything and i said it's a book i'm
working on
right now it's a class i teach a class
on i've been teaching for about 10 years
my most popular class
but here's the premise that women have
to experience
emotional tension have attraction
arousal towards a man and stay attached
to him over time
but here's the problem we men tend to
not like emotional tension
especially in our relationships we want
everything calm
smooth locked down once we fix something
we want it to stay fixed
even our sporting events that have
emotional tension have a clock on them
we can only take it for so long
you know we we want everything to get
back to calm back to good
so as women need this emotional tension
to feel attracted and arousal
with a man and we men especially nice
guys are either doing nothing to create
it
trying to please a woman listen to her
talk about her problems
paying her car payment helping her
sister move that creates no tension
for a woman they they just they just
will take advantage of that
but that guy that's not particularly
available to him that's always checking
out the other women
that sometimes they're sometimes not not
dependable
that's all emotional tension now it's
what i call negative
emotional tension because it doesn't
particularly feel good
but it's still emotional tension right
and what i
say guys in the book i'm working on in
my class is that for most women
they don't intellectually care if it's
positive emotional tension
or negative emotional tension they need
the tension to feel connected so for
example
you and i as married men when we're not
creating enough emotional tension for
our partner
she will create emotional tension to get
our attention to get us to get a bond
you know whatever they they learn really
early what what gets us wound up
whether it's the silent treatment
whether it's nagging or complaining
throwing some dishes in the sink you
know
flirting with our best friend they find
out early what
what winds us up when they're not
feeling enough emotional tension
they'll create that that negative
emotional tension that gets us wound up
now for us we're going i don't like this
but it worked we're wound up
there's connection there like like my
wife says
you know i don't like it when other
women flirt with you it makes me jealous
but it creates emotional tension that's
not her words it's mine
it turns me on right now since she's
aroused and more attracted to me
because other women want me now the book
in the class
tells men how to be conscious of
creating a positive emotional tension
that turns a woman on just will turn
women on in general but in marriage
their partner on
in ways that are not manipulative that
are not playing games
they're just more conscious and i was
talking earlier about
living life on your terms being
comfortable in your own skin showing up
and setting the tone taking the lead
being assertive those are all things
that create positive emotional tension
for women
now i don't teach this like a pickup
technique well this will turn on every
woman it doesn't
but it does make you more attractive and
it is arousing
to a woman who's already got high
interest in wanting to be close to you
so that's why they're attracted to the
bad boys and why the nice guys bore them
the bad boy creates negative tension
it's unpredictable it's uncertain you
know they got to work hard to try to get
his approval and
get him to show up um they don't have to
do any of that work with the nice guy
and so they get bored he doesn't create
all the drama for them
but you know but it's boring right it
doesn't light them up or make them wet
either
you know but the bad boy does so so
there's they're they're not a happy
middle ground but there is an answer and
that answer
is in the way i look at it is in
positive emotional tension
got it so what you're saying is pull the
umbrella away
from them so they can get wet because
sometimes when it rains you gotta you
gotta let that happen you gotta let them
very very philosophical you sounded a
little bit like socrates aristotle type
of sex uh
relationship tips you gave right there
so so here's a here's a crazy
question for you see how you process
this what's better for you is it better
to be with somebody that
you're crazy about that you end up
getting
or is it better for you to be with
somebody that's crazy about you
but maybe you weren't as crazy about
them yeah you know
unfortunately most relationships
one is a little bit more crazy about the
other than the other
and and and i've seen that over the
years i've been there
over the years my personal answer is i'd
rather be with the woman that makes me
nuts and drives me crazy
they're making nuts they drive you crazy
you're crazy about her
yeah that well they don't have the power
to make you nuts unless you're crazy
about them right
you know if you're not crazy about them
they won't make you nuts
so they answer your question yeah i'd
much rather be with someone that makes
me crazy
so then the then before we wrap up this
you said this your third marriage four
years
we just celebrated fourth anniversary
lupita right congratulations for that
thank you
do you think this is the one i don't
think in terms of that
you know um
the whole other 90-minute interview is
that long-term pair-bonded monogamous
relationships are not
natural for humans but are they powerful
personal growth machines if we do them
consciously
yes um do i love getting waking up every
morning next to this woman and do i want
to spend the rest of my life waking up
to her
that's my prayer so i think what you're
saying is you prefer term limits in
marriage is that a
like you know four eight years twelve
years and you campaign every four years
to keep it going
yeah maybe that's better than the
supreme court make them you know for
life
um no what i what i like best is as long
as both of you enjoy each other yeah and
like being together
let's show up and keep working on this
thing let's make it
let's make it the best we can and my my
wife and i will joke about having a
competition
to see who who can out love each other
who can out gift each other
and um and it is it's a way we play with
each other but
it it sure is good for the marriage why
is it that some of the best books
written on relationship and marriage are
written by people that have had divorces
why do you think that how else you gonna
learn man i i tell people i
bumbled my way through every
relationship i've had
i'm still bumbling my way you know going
back to everything we've talked about
every wounding we've had in life
everything that's happened to us
affects our ability to get close to
people and that includes the people
we're trying to get close to
their have their issues to get close to
us this is challenging
this is work it doesn't come easy it
doesn't come naturally
but i'll say it again it's a powerful
personal growth machine if we show up
with love and consciousness
well first of all i've really enjoyed
the time here with you uh i'm glad
i spoke about you i'm glad my booker is
good enough to have contacted you and
i'm glad you said yes
because i think a lot of people probably
took a lot of different things away here
from
our conversation here do you have any
final thoughts you want to say to the
men
and women who were with us the last 90
minutes
how about this if you want an exciting
life live an honest life
be open be transparent be what you see
is what you get life stays interesting
that way
having said that thank you for your 90
minutes wish you nothing
but the very best and we're looking
forward to your next book coming out
hopefully next year thank you patrick
take care a topic you rarely hear people
talk about i mean obviously a lot of
people talk about it
it's a topic as adults you enjoy talking
about sex all this stuff but
not often from the effects of what
happened when we were this age and how
it led to us being a different kind of
an adult
as a man and why this worked out and
that didn't work out and sex and
marriage and parents and humiliation and
all this other stuff and obviously had a
great time with them i really enjoyed
the sit down i'm curious to know what
you took away from him so if you want to
comment below as well as if you enjoyed
this interview
i did another interview similar to this
we didn't go that much deep into uh
uh sex as we did with this one but it's
a similar style in the vfd i've never
seen my interview with uh
a professor daniel lieberman click over
here to watch it and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye